well everyone welcome uh thank you for
braving the snow mounds around new haven
and uh making it in today for the talk
uh my name is stuart deku i'm the
program director at the yale center for
business the environment and this is the
second talk in the sabin sustainable
venture prize speaker series uh the talk
is sponsored as i said by the yale
center for business environment
broadcast simultaneously through the
yale youtube channel welcome to those of
you both in our audience here and online
a little bit about the saban prize um it
is a student faculty it supports student
and faculty efforts to start a
sustainable for-profit business through
cash prizes totaling 25 000
this venture prize competition and the
date of the application date for those
here at yale is march 22nd for everyone
to get in their applications
um provides quality feedback from
professional judges extensive mentoring
from faculty and opportunities for
participants to meet and pitch their
ideas to top venture capitalists and
leading industry professionals
today we're really pleased on a number
of levels to welcome andrew shapiro a
cba advisory board member
someone who is a serial entrepreneur
and
really a great friend of yale and of
efforts here to help create the kind of
disruptive technologies and businesses
which can translate into
real environmental and economic change
in his talk scaling up innovation andrew
will be addressing the new strategies
available to increase the diffusion and
commercial success of new technologies
and business models
andrew as i mentioned spent the last two
decades working at the nexus of new
technologies and societal transformation
with a focus over the last dozen years
on energy and environmental innovation
he recently founded broadscale group a
new model of investment firm that is
working with a network of leading energy
corporations including duke energy ge
and national grid to invest in and
commercialize the industry's most
promising innovations
in 2000 andrew founded green order a
strategic advisory firm that worked with
more than a dozen a hundred leading
enterprises he has invested and advised
more than a dozen startups fortune
recently described him as green
businesses go-to guy
andrew is a graduate of brown university
and yale law school and has held
teaching appointments and research
fellowships at columbia harvard and yale
and he serves as i mentioned on the
advisory board of the yale center for
business the environment please join me
in welcoming welcoming andrew shapiro to
the 2012-2013
saban sustainable venture prize speaker
series
thank you stuart and thank you all for
braving the weather to get here
uh i'm really pleased to be back at yale
i've spent the day here today
and other than navigating my way through
eight foot mounds of snow on the
sidewalk it's it's been a real
a pleasure to be back um
you know it is kind of fitting that uh
we're having this discussion about new
strategies to innovate around energy and
resources at a time
when last night in the state of the
union
president obama spoke
i think at more length about climate
change and the need for energy
innovation than he has probably in any
state of the union
thus far in his presidency and also at a
time when you know we're just grappling
with the reality of extreme weather
events in our
uh everyday lives i mean the fact that
this area of connecticut had three feet
of snow
over this past weekend is really kind of
remarkable so i think it's a wake-up
call and a good time for us to have this
dialogue and conversation so i'm looking
forward to it i'm going to speak for
roughly 30 minutes
give you a little bit of perspective on
scaling up innovation as i think about
it and then i'm really looking forward
to your feedback and your questions and
a dialogue with all of you so i hope
you'll think about questions i know some
of you have already been giving thought
to questions you sent some my way that
were really great ones so i look forward
to the conversation with all of you
so a little bit more about my
perspective
i started a firm called green order in
2000
that worked with large companies and
works with large companies today
to help make energy and environmental
innovation a source of competitive
advantage and we've worked with a really
broad array of industries and corporate
leaders as stuart said
there's just a couple of examples here
on this slide but more than 100
companies across diverse industries
we were very fortunate to start working
with general electric in 2004
help them to create their business
strategy around clean technology called
eco-imagination some of you have
probably seen the marketing but
at its heart eco imagination was a
business strategy to invest in clean
technology and innovation around energy
and environment and so
i'll come back to the work that we've
done with ge it's really central to
where i've gone in my career over the
last seven or eight years
i also have had the occasion to work on
some other
fun and interesting projects we worked
with general motors on the launch of the
chevrolet volt
which was really a pioneering electric
vehicle
worked with silverstein properties in
new york on the creation of seven world
trade center the first building that
went up at ground zero which was the
first leed certified office tower in new
york city
and we worked with leading energy
companies like duke energy and national
grid and others
so i've had the benefit of working
across a variety of different sectors
and seeing how large corporates think
about
these issues
and the reason i'm excited
about this space is while there are
great challenges ahead of us when it
comes to energy security and
environmental issues and climate change
there's also great opportunity
uh and that opportunity i see is the
opportunity to solve our resource
challenges using innovation if we look
at the fundamentals and those of you who
are here in the school of forestry and
environmental studies you you know all
this uh well but
there are some key drivers that i think
make this an exciting area to focus on
for the next
generations to come 20 30 40 years first
the sheer fact that our population is
growing at such a a huge clip
towards 10 billion people globally
the fact that three billion people will
join the middle class by 2030.
uh tom friedman of the new york times
likes to say that people all over the
world are going to want to live like
americans and while that's a great thing
in some ways it also means that the
pressure and constraints on our natural
resources are going to be huge
and that means that we must figure out
new ways to make energy water
forestry other resources abundant
cleaner and more efficient and so i
think that is really the task of the
21st century and it's why i'm doing this
work and i'm sure why so many of you are
as well
we need to innovate in how we produce
and create
essentially everything in our society
and that leads me to this kind of big
metaphysical question if you will which
is what do we mean when we talk about
innovation we use that term so much
right and i think it's worth stepping
back and kind of asking ourselves what
is innovation really all about
because it's easy to kind of quickly say
well innovation that's about technology
but it's about more than technology it's
also about culture
and it's more than just great big ideas
as i'll talk about further it's also
about having the courage to take action
and to actually be willing to fail and
make mistakes
so let's explore a little bit about how
both big corporate actors and others are
thinking about innovation
so leading companies are trying to
innovate to solve problems they see
market opportunities they see an ability
to bring new products and services to
market
they also want to improve their own
performance right they know that if they
can operate more efficiently they can
produce greater profitability more
enterprise value
they want to create products and
services that the market wants and by
innovating they hope to do that and
ultimately increase market share and get
price premiums and loyalty in the market
and they want better engagement with the
marketplace that means with public
stakeholders
but it also means
accessing innovation no matter where it
may be
and so companies like general electric
and others are embracing this concept of
open innovation and even though they
have huge resources and investments in
their own r d
general electric for example across
their global research centers has 3 000
scientists who do nothing but look at
new technologies and applications and
that's outside of their business units
where they have thousands of more
technologists and r d folks looking at
new ideas
so open innovation is this concept of
looking outside the four walls of the
enterprise whether it's investing in
university research or looking at
investing in new startups or working
collaboratively with others in the
marketplace
and this is a big economic opportunity
mckinsey put out a study last year
saying that over the next 20 years there
is three trillion dollars in economic
benefit by improving resource efficiency
in the global marketplace so there's a
lot at stake here and a lot of reason to
focus for big companies on this area
these are big markets
at the same time you've got some of the
most talented entrepreneurs and
investors who have gravitated into the
energy and resources area
because they see the same economic
opportunity and because they're driven
by ideals and values and they want to
make a difference in the world and
that's incredibly exciting to me
i started in this space in 2000
sort of at the height of the dot-com
bubble
and there were not that many people at
that time who were kind of clamoring to
get into clean energy or sustainable
transportation or green buildings and
infrastructure but that has happened
over the last five years you've seen
some of the best entrepreneurs who went
from starting companies in the tech
space into into clean energy
one of the ones who i think people are
talking about a lot these days is elon
musk who was a co-founder of paypal and
then went on to start tesla and is also
the chairman of solarcity
so you've seen this huge influx of
capital both from venture capitalists
and private equity and project finance
investors going into clean energy and
according to bloomberg new energy
finance we're at about 270 billion
dollars uh last year and while those
numbers have kind of gone up and down a
little bit it's a huge amount of capital
relative to what it was five years ago
and in many ways on par with the
investment that's going into traditional
fossil fuel resources
and clean tech you know even though it's
had its tough time over the last few
years represents something like
one-fifth of all the venture investment
that's happening in the united states
and similar amounts abroad as well
as i said there are new actors and
participants coming into this market
folks who bring tremendous
technological capability and scientific
prowess and i think that's exciting and
overall you're seeing more new solutions
technologies more new products and
companies come into this space than ever
before and i think that's reason to be
optimistic
and sanguine about where we're going
at the same time
we have to be frank with ourselves and i
think this community
sometimes is not willing to look hard
truths in the eye
and the truth is if you step back and
ask yourselves how much progress has
been made in clean technology and in
clean energy over the last decade the
truth is we're not moving fast enough if
we look at any of the big areas energy
generation green buildings sustainable
transportation
we're coming up with new products and
services but they're not scaling up fast
enough they're not commercializing
they're not reaching a mass audience
so i ask all of you i mean think about
how many new companies or products you
can think of that over the last five or
seven or even 10 years have gone
completely mainstream in this space and
you can probably count them on one hand
when we get to the q and a maybe we can
talk about some because i'd love to hear
if you can name you know more than five
most people can't
so why is that i mean first off and here
we are in the academy we have to ask
ourselves
are there failures of public policy and
i think most of us would say yes both on
the international stage i think the un
framework while
uh you know a good attempt has not
gotten us where we want to go in terms
of action on climate change on the
national stage in the united states we
also have not made the progress in terms
of energy and climate policy even though
there have been some good attempts and
some good efforts in specific areas like
fuel economy
at the state and regional level there
are some more reasons to be i think
pleased with the achievements that we've
made and particularly i'm excited about
some of the efforts that cities have
made and regions have made whether you
look at the new england region or
california
but there's also realities around
economics right most people know that
with natural gas prices where they are
two three dollars a million btu it's
very hard for alternative technologies
in energy and transportation
even
impacting the infrastructure space to
compete and so that's one of the
realities of why a lot of these
solutions haven't scaled up that fast
and then
i always like to say think about it you
know two guys in a garage
cannot disrupt the power sector right
here we are we're in the general motors
room i don't think gm is concerned about
two guys in a garage coming up with a
vehicle that's going to completely upend
gm now gm has had other challenges over
the recent years but they're coming back
strong post bankruptcy
but if you think about our whole
conception of startups and disruptive
innovation right the whole history of it
is really
about the renegade entrepreneur think
about hewlett and packard who created
the whole personal computer revolution
at the start or steve jobs and steve
wozniak with apple or bill gates uh and
his colleagues at microsoft or later
larry and sergey at google
or mark zuckerberg at facebook these
were all examples of literally in most
of those in cases these were guys in a
garage not gals but guys but there are
certainly stories of gals doing it too
who are creating new products and
solutions that upended industries and
created multi-billion dollar enterprises
and we don't see that in the energy
sector we don't see that in
transportation and water and waste and
other sectors that are relevant to the
issues we're talking about today
this has led a lot of the analysts in
the sector to talk about this idea of a
valley of death right and it's not just
a technology valley of death where
you're working to perfect
a new solution or a new
technology application it's a
commercialization value of death which
is essentially a fancy way of saying
that even if you can create the widget
that will change the world if you can't
figure out how to get it to market how
to make it economical on a per unit
basis it's very hard to compete with the
existing solutions and that means for
many new clean technology
products and solutions that have been
created it's very hard for them to go up
against the incumbent technologies
so
all of this has led me over recent years
to think we really need to step back and
ask ourselves what are we talking about
when we talk about innovation because we
get excited about new technologies and
new ideas
but the truth is if we think about
innovation and what it really means in
terms of its impact
innovation is about more than ideas
innovation has to be innovation excuse
me innovation has to be ideas
as applied
and implemented at scale
i mean it's a little bit to me like the
story about if a tree falls in the
forest right
that old kind of cohen if a tree falls
in the forest and nobody hears it
has it actually happened
that's the same thing with innovation if
you come up with a brilliant idea
but it is not implemented at scale
that is an innovation that's simply a
concept or an idea or something that's
on the drawing board which has yet to be
applied and to change the world to make
an impact whether it's environmentally
financially
from the other perspectives that we
might take national security public
health
we have to take these ideas and apply
them and implement them at scale in
order to really make a difference
so let me then step back and tell you
how we're trying to work on these issues
at broad scale
as we look at the marketplace of these
new ideas if you think about it there
are a lot of fantastic new technologies
and companies that have been launched
over the last five to seven years and in
fact it's been a fertile period as i
said there's been more venture capital
going into this
space than ever before there's been more
project finance capital
corporates are more involved so you have
great companies that are being created
great ideas that are
coming into the market
but the truth is very few of them are
getting through this funnel of
commercialization to the end
they may be raising capital moving
forward in their commercial plan and
getting to growth stage but then they
get stuck in this valley of death as we
discussed before
so what's the best way to actually drive
impact and we've been thinking about it
and we've come up with what we think is
a new approach
let me actually before i get there pause
with a quick historical side note
here again since we're at yale i can't
resist but telling you a little story
and this is actually from a book
written by my friend stephen johnson
the book is called future perfect
stephen writes about innovation and
science his last book was called where
good ideas come from a natural history
of innovation
and he looked at what were the best
mechanisms to drive progress in society
and basically because he's a theorist
about technology and innovation he
looked historical examples and he came
up with this interesting example this is
the french railroad system that was
created in the mid 19th century
by a
designer named victor legrand who was
commissioned by the french government to
create a rail system this was of course
the cutting edge technology at the time
and he created what can only be thought
to be an incredibly
elegant
system and design for a national
railroad
highly centralized
very top-down
beautifully architected
but at the end of the day
not that efficient
and the place where that became clearest
was during the franco-prussian war in
1870 when the french and german went to
war
on this eastern front of france
and the germans had a huge advantage
because they had rail lines they were
far more decentralized
there were
multiple redundant lines to get german
soldiers to the front
and they were able to use those rail
lines to get
troops and munitions there faster than
the french could and most military
historians chalk up the german victory
in that war partly to the difference in
the architecture of their respective
rail networks
now we may have historians in the room
who know better than i but what i find
fascinating about this story was that
the best laid plans of the french in
coming up with a perfect system for a
rail architecture
were upended by something that wasn't
created top down that wasn't by design
centralized and was in fact quite
hodgepodge
and stephen johnson says we need to
learn from this and look at other
systems that can actually be much more
efficient in terms of scaling up
impact and ideas
the alternative he says is think about
the value of distributed decentralized
networks and he actually fast forwards
from the mid 1800s excuse me yeah the
mid-1800s into the mid-1900s 100 almost
100 years later
to the work of a communications theorist
named paul buran
now paul buran was a researcher at the
rand corporation
and he was given a complex problem to
solve which was how do we create
a communications infrastructure that can
survive a nuclear
bomb
this was just at the time when nuclear
weaponry
was
being used for the first time and the
real scare was
based on the centrality of the
communications network could the entire
network be taken down because of single
points of vulnerability
and what beran came up with was rather
than a centralized network as you see on
the left or even a decentralized network
in the middle with multiple nodes
was
the value of having a highly distributed
network such as the one that you see on
the right where there would be no
central node or even not that many
decentralized nodes but multiple nodes
and redundancies now those of you who
have spent any time studying the history
of the internet
know that brands work and this
distributed network went on to influence
and ultimately inform the very structure
that created the internet and so when
people have talked about the internet
was created to withstand you know a
nuclear bomb that was brand's work at
rand which ultimately impacted
communications and network theory and
led to the creations of all the
protocols that underlie the internet
today
so i'm taking that historical detour
because i want to talk for a moment
about our theory on how to create and
scale up innovation and how to do so in
a way that will be most impactful and
most efficient and essentially
we are drawing from this network theory
to say
that we need another approach to think
about how we take those great ideas in
the energy and resource space
and scale them up at impact and that
approach is one of relying on the power
of networks
so rather than the historical model
where
companies have been funded and grown and
then gone out to market to find
customers wherever they might be
we are trying to create a structure
that's network-based bringing in a group
of corporations
who can be both customers for those new
technologies and innovations
as well as sponsors in terms of
providing capital to those companies as
well as partners in terms of
commercialization distribution and other
sources of value manufacturing and
licensing partnerships financing
and
this is interesting
outlook uh
really key partners in scaling up
these new innovations and technologies
that are being brought to market
so we are borrowing from network theory
to try to find
a new way to accelerate
the creation of clean energy
technologies and ideas that can change
the world
we're starting in the power sector as i
think i said earlier with
representation from ge
duke energy the largest utility in the
united states and national grid which is
the largest
power company in the united kingdom but
also owns utility assets here in the
northeast of the u.s
but our aspiration over time is to go
into adjacent areas so areas like oil
and gas and transportation and real
estate and infrastructure and water
and waste and food and agriculture
and materials
and the reasoning there is that these
clusters
while distinct industry areas are
increasingly overlapping and the power
will be in pulling together different
companies across these industry areas
into the kind of robust distributed
network
that bran wrote about and ultimately
helped influence the creation of our
contemporary internet-based economy
and so what we're hoping to do over time
is create
a distributed network of large
corporates who can help take these ideas
and take them to scale
so our approach is what we call the
formation of creative networks of
collaboration
and this is a phrase that actually i
would say we to some degree borrowed
from president bill clinton who's been
talking about the power of collaboration
and networks as well
we added the idea of trying to make them
more creative networks because we think
that we need to go beyond traditional
modes of collaboration and partnership
and by that
what do we mean
well the first thing is
we're not just interested in putting
capital to work in companies what we're
trying to facilitate here
is
yes capital but also commercialization
partnerships that can help accelerate
these technologies overcome that valley
of death that we talked about earlier if
we don't do that we know that a lot of
these companies even with a lot of
capital
may not succeed there are just too many
difficult
uh challenges in the process of scaling
up these businesses of finding the
channels to market of having the
confidence of the end users in the
market
to go it alone
we're also looking to try to aggregate
demand among different players in our
network so if we can pull together
multiple companies that can share the
risk we can actually help technologies
to get to market faster
in terms of network theory the benefits
to our members include greater
efficiency in terms of transaction costs
and information costs they can share the
burden of evaluating new companies and
technologies and they can also begin to
share information amongst one another
in ways that will give them greater
insight and intelligence into the market
and these new
technologies and then lastly the kind of
collaborative model we're talking about
is one in which both
the large corporate network members and
the startup companies that we're working
with benefit both sides get something
out of the equation
and the best news is that there are
positive externalities meaning that
society at large benefits because if we
can accelerate the deployment of these
new technologies they're all
technologies that will help reduce
environmental impacts improve efficiency
and create a more sustainable economy
so our power network which we've just
started uh formally this year
has
members of electric utilities technology
companies like ge and then service
companies as well that we're bringing in
we are looking at issues across the
range of the power sector from
generation and transmission to smart
grid and
distributed generation into issues
around data and energy storage and
emissions control
we're working with a whole group of
resources and affiliates including
pegasus capital advisors which is a
private equity firm in new york which
we're working with
public utility commissions so that we
can help to educate regulators about
what's happening and other key
organizations we're working with eei and
epre in the power sector as well as
trade groups and ngos and legal firms
and the way that we will activate the
network is
through these multiple different modes
of action so we're looking to drive
co-investment from our network so
capital is a part of the equation but
it's i would say necessary but not
sufficient in itself
we're driving joint ventures around
technology and operations including
manufacturing
we're hoping to create distribution
deals where larger companies can take
the new tools and technologies that
smaller companies are creating and help
get them to market
as well as facilitating strategic
procurement so that
large companies can be working together
to find the best technologies to meet
their needs
let me give you a quick case study to
kind of
make more concrete what i'm talking
about
recycle bank is a company that i'm
involved in uh they actually acquired a
small business that i started and i'm on
their advisory board
and they have done a really interesting
partnership that's kind of emblematic uh
of what broad scale is all about
they're working with waste management um
and let me just start by saying recycle
bank for those of you don't know it is a
novel loyalty and rewards program that
incentivizes people to recycle more
they've figured out a way to
essentially quantify and measure how
much consumers recycle and reward them
for that with points that can be used at
different retailers
and this company was actually named the
number one clean tech firm vc backed
firm
by the wall street journal this year and
last year so it's gotten a lot of
attention
the partnership with waste management
involves a number of different
components waste management made a major
equity investment in the company
they've also shared with recyclebank a
platform that they had in the loyalty
and incentive space to do something
different so they sort of decided to go
all in
and bring those two solutions together
and then perhaps most importantly
waste management the largest player in
the
waste and recycling space in the united
states is giving recycle bank the
opportunity to have its solution sold in
the marketplace by their own sales
people out in the field
and who knows better how to get these
solutions activated with municipalities
and cities around the world than waste
management they're the largest player
there
so what we have here is a creative
collaboration between a new player
recycle bank that was bringing
a new approach to trying to incentivize
recycling and waste management the
largest player in the field which saw a
need to work with an innovative external
partner to come up with a new solution
and they're collaborating and the
results so far have been i think beyond
their expectations
while i can't give you the exact numbers
because it's a private company i know
from my engagement that
the results are
very dramatic in terms of reducing the
sales cycle
the time to close contracts and growing
the number of customers that recycle
bank has had and so it's a good example
of the kind of
good outcome you can come you can get
when you put together a partnership like
this
another example i wanted to mention is
silver spring networks silver spring is
a smart grid uh technology company which
is working with utilities
around the world it's been a leader in
this space
and interestingly just over the last
year or so they've forged two
partnerships with large corporations
both of those partnerships involved
equity investment again but they didn't
stop there they also involve joint r d
and development of solutions and
products to the market together so with
hitachi they are entering the
international market and particularly
japan
and with emc which is a company that
focuses on the data space they're
developing new solutions around big data
to analyze uh utility information and
make it more valuable to their end
customers so it's another interesting
example of of how
uh
two large incumbent players are working
with a younger company that's a leader
in the space
and then the third one i'll mention is
tesla and we talked briefly i mentioned
elon musk before but when i speak to
audiences i often ask them you know
what's the most successful new
energy or resource company or clean tech
company if you want to call it that and
people often say well you know maybe
tesla they've had one of the most
successful ipos of any company in this
space and certainly have gotten a lot of
press and mind share around the vehicles
they've created
and one of the things that i think is
notable it's not often talked about but
they did this with the support of three
major companies which could have looked
at tesla as a competitor but instead of
embrace the opportunity to work with
them learn from them
take advantage of the entrepreneurial
culture that they have
and of course tesla has gotten benefits
from these relationships as well
as in the previous examples i mentioned
each one of these companies panasonic
daimler and toyota are strategic
investors in tesla
they invested a key moment just before
the company went public so it gave
kind of endorsement or validation of the
company at a key moment when they were
just entering the public market but each
has developed different strategic
relationships as well around product
development
joint r d
commercial deployment and so you'll see
tesla working with toyota on their rav4
vehicle or you'll see them working with
panasonic on the development of new
battery technologies
and these are the kinds of strategic
partnerships that we think need to
happen more
and for which there needs to be a more
efficient marketplace so in many ways
what we're trying to do at broad scale
is take these kinds of relationships
that companies are forging uh you know
with the the most promising new startups
in the space and create a marketplace
for those kinds of partnerships that's
more efficient
faster and more dynamic so really
thinking about it in a clearinghouse
model imagine if there was one place you
could go
where you knew that you could get access
to
all the corporates that were interested
in investing in or partnering with
promising startups in this space and it
just today doesn't exist if you ask
entrepreneurs if you ask venture
capitalists they'll say it's a very ad
hoc
process
it really
increasingly depends on personal
relationships that folks have
and it's slow and it's inefficient we
think that we can create through the
kind of network approach that i
mentioned a more efficient process a
more valuable process for all involved
reducing
the time needed to identify and forge
those partnerships and ultimately
accelerating innovation and the impacts
that we're all looking for
in sum then
i would include by saying that scaling
up innovation more than anything
requires new modes of collaboration
i think that what we're trying to do at
broad scale is one
dimension or one way of driving that
partnership and collaboration but there
are many more
i was speaking with some of you earlier
today about the need to have government
involved and the different modes and
ways in which
government can act whether it's as a
regulator or as a funder or even using
its procurement power and i believe
that's a key part of the equation
we ourselves are focused on what i would
think of as instead of public-private
collaboration private private
collaboration which is a key part of it
but i think that what we need to do
today as a society to drive progress and
change on these issues is
do everything we can to forge new kinds
of partnerships and collaboration that
will unlock the opportunity that we know
is there in these new technologies and
solutions that people are developing
only by tapping into that creative
entrepreneurial zeal that can be found
in startups
and then connecting that to
the unique resources that you can only
find in large companies whether it's the
technological know-how
the customer relationships the channels
into the marketplace and also yes the
balance sheets of those companies which
have a lot of capital and cash available
only through those two
different components do i think we'll
get to the place we need when it comes
to scaling up innovation and achieving
impacts so i hope
that some of you
will leave here and go on to find ways
to forge those partnerships maybe there
are ways we can collaborate and work on
it together and i also welcome your
ideas on other ways to achieve the
outcomes that we're all looking for
thanks very much
so let me open it up to questions i know
uh some of you
have
been giving some thought to questions
and ideas because i got some good ones
sent to me in advance but i'd love to
hear your thoughts and questions and if
you wouldn't mind just tell me who you
are and which school you might be
affiliated with if any
there's a mic there as well
ryan
joint degree first a first year joint
degree student with school of management
in the school of forestry um i was just
wondering whether you anticipate
creating
partnerships between the growth
companies themselves is i i have the
feeling that
some
technologies will have synergistic
effects if if those those two companies
are combined or um
work in a network with the the larger
companies
do you anticipate that
absolutely it's a great insight and as
we've spent a good portion of the last
year talking to some of the smartest
venture capitalists entrepreneurs and
other kind of observers in the market
one of the pieces of feedback we've
gotten is there are too many companies
trying to do the exact same thing or
there are complementary companies that
have different solutions which would
benefit by working more closely together
or even merging i think we're going to
see more of that activity in the years
to come
and part of it is that the nature of the
venture capital model is that they want
to launch lots of different businesses
and see kind of who can get to the
finish line but in this market you need
more collaboration and less kind of
cutthroat competition so
i think a lot of these businesses are
figuring out ways to collaborate and
some of the exciting things you'll see
will come from actors you might think
are natural allies and some from
you know companies you would never have
expected would be working together
yeah in the back there
hey i'm jeff woodward i'm a second year
joint degree student between the school
management and school forestry
um traditionally in entrepreneurship
there's a little bit of hesitancy about
partnering with a strategic investor
early on
because there's concern that it kind of
limits acquisition opportunities from
another strategic investor or creates
other perverse incentives
you seem to be in some of these cases
advocating for that
um
do you think that there's somewhat of a
different model here because of
different needs of the space and
that or can you talk a little bit more
about that or how as an earlier stage
company that might want to partner with
the strategic how you mitigate that
great question and that is a concern
that entrepreneurs have um
first off i should clarify that most of
the companies we're going to be working
with
um you know we we call them startups or
really try to talk about the moore's
growth companies
because some of them have actually been
around for some time they just have had
trouble scaling up
but most of them won't be early stage
because unless they are
business model innovations which don't
have a lot of technology risk by
nature
they're going to have to be working out
the technology kinks and kind of going
through that development cycle
by the time they get to the point where
they're really ready to partner with a
strategic i think they'll be later in
their development and that probably will
be less of a concern and to be honest as
i've talked to folks in the marketplace
they are eager to to embrace those
partnerships because they see them as a
huge opportunity now it doesn't mean
that they're not concerned about
limiting their exit options or even
their
strategic procurement options because
you know if they get too close to any
one large strategic maybe others be
concerned but i've actually been
surprised the degree to which multiple
strategics or investing in the same
company or i mean you just saw an
acquisition that was announced i think
this week
toshiba announced it's buying a company
called concert
concert has multiple other corporate
strategic investors in the company so
right there it blows that you know
hypothesis out of the water you know i
don't know if they thought there were
limitations but
so these things are happening in the
market and i think given
the tough circumstances that a lot of
these young companies are facing they're
going to have to figure out how they
partner with strategics
yeah
hi thank you for joining us my name is
rafael torres i'm a joint degree third
year between som and fes
my question is uh of course in terms of
scaling up innovation the power sector
is uh a doozy um
and you know part of the reason for that
is because you have these very large
assets that are very long-lived right
you have when you talk about utility
scale you know generation transmission
distribution
um
and so these assets are supposed to be
in
online for
30 40 50 years
and you you have long term contracts
and so of course that dynamic lends
itself to the fact that you have a very
big installed base and the amount that
you install in any given year
is kind of small so
it you know that kind of makes it
challenging for new innovations to break
in on a bigger scale because you've been
locked out
of all the existing installations that
have already been put in place how do
you envision trying to get past that
blockage
without
sort of recurring to the policy route
which is sort of stuck
or you know i mean you could kind of do
it easier for the distributed
excuse me generation side but it's kind
of much much harder for the utility
scale side right
so this is a great question um utilities
are not easy to work with because of the
regulated
dimension of them obviously there are a
lot of uh
investor-owned utilities that now have
regulated and deregulated components and
one
thing we might look at is you know where
we work with these companies and where
they try to deploy assets whether it's
on the d-reg versus the regulated side
the other thing is there are things that
are occurring uh
long-term trends that are going to i
think
dramatically impact how the industry
thinks about innovation and change
look at the rise of uh distributed solar
as a trend
i think the utility industry is looking
at increasingly now some parts of the
utility industry are getting nervous
about it they're starting to see load
that's being taken from them by dg
customers some are pushing back on net
mirroring laws
but that means to me that kind of where
there's those kinds of concerns there's
also opportunities for forward thinking
uh utilities and so dg solar is i think
an area of interest so is the whole
issue of you know smart grid and grid
modernization
where you know if we can figure out ways
for utilities to be actively involved in
that uh then they won't be
disintermediated by other players but
you know that's a real issue and concern
as well and so there are a lot of pain
points but also areas i think that bring
opportunity as a result of that and
we're going to have to be creative in
looking at the regulatory model and
where we play in that sector but i agree
with you
yeah
my name is ray and i'm a second year at
the school of forestry i'm interested in
learning about um how the relationship
between
let's say a strategic and a smaller
company changes as they scale up um i'm
interested in hearing your perspective
about how the kind of carrots that um
each of these players pursue the
benefits that they pursue
change
i can imagine that for waste management
they in a way must admire the business
model of
recycle bank and in a way want to
emulate it
and then as recycle bank uh scales up
through using uh waste management's
assets maybe it'll run into different
kinds of problems um so how did the how
did the you know benefits uh evolve
that's a good question i i you know
nobody knows exactly how these
partnerships will evolve um but it's
certainly conceivable that you know as
the smaller entity grows and if the
partnership you know gets close enough
i mean there was an acquisition
announced a few weeks ago
where
one of the innovative new companies in
the sharing economy the maybe the most
best
known one zipcar
agreed to be acquired by avis
and you know you kind of think to
yourself well that's interesting i
wonder why that happened and i think one
of the dynamics there was probably the
fact that uh
as zipcar started to impact the market
with this short-term rental model other
players in the market got into it as
well the big incumbents so hertz
launched an offering that looked a whole
lot like that where they were allowing
hourly rentals and doing it on campuses
and so on and i think ava's just sort of
decided you know they could partner with
zipcar or they could just acquire them
and they decided to acquire them so i
think you're going to see a lot more of
that where you know
companies are going to have to make
decisions as they partner and grow
together do they stay separate do they
acquire do they joint venture
but all of that should be ultimately in
the name of getting those new
innovations to market
yes
hi thanks for coming my name is will
george i'm a first year in the forestry
school
and i was wondering can you talk a
little bit about the portfolio of
companies that you have in terms of
business model innovation versus
technology innovation and
kind of
you know do you have a certain do you
like a certain
you know percentage of each or
do the companies that you work with
are they looking for
one more than the other right
so
i can't talk about any specific
companies yet because we haven't
announced any deals but we are working
with a number of companies on the growth
stage side and some of them are business
model innovations and some of them are
technology and i think it will continue
to be a fair split of those two
the advantage business model innovations
as i kind of referenced before is that
you don't have as much technology risk
and so they might be perfectly situated
to partner with a large corporate to get
more traction in the market
uh because they don't present a whole
lot of risk uh in terms of technology
actually the example i just mentioned
would be a good one right zipcar they're
not
recreating the vehicle they're not an
electric vehicle company they're not a
natural gas vehicle company they're not
you know even taking on the internal
combustion engine in any way
they are a business model innovation and
thus it was very easy for a larger
corporate like avis to
get involved and acquire them
because it wasn't you know making sure
that the technology worked for example
you know a lot of ev car companies out
there that have had some technological
challenges with the battery and so on so
that would be a good example
but i think we're going to continue to
see both i think business model
innovations often get overlooked
in the whole discussion about you know
how we innovate and create change and
and there can be powerful things
happening there i mean look at what's
happening in solar
where the manufacturers of solar have
had a very challenging time over the
last year but some of the great success
stories are coming from business model
innovations around leasing
ppas you know this whole no money down
model and that that's driving a huge
amount of adoption in the market
any other questions
yeah
i have another one um so i was wondering
about the scale of capital uh you know
because
again power sector obviously very
capital intensive
um
and sometimes this commercialization
value of death is is framed as a problem
of you know there's just doesn't seem to
be enough money to put at risk
considering that particular risk profile
it seems like
venture capital you have different
segments right vc you have pe like vc
wants to do
you know small investments you know
decent hefty amount of risk but you know
smaller investments pe wants to do
bigger investments but moderate to lower
kind of risk you know there doesn't seem
to be a good space for
large amount of money large risk which
seems to be where a lot of these
projects fall so i was kind of wondering
is there a gap there uh that the
just the epc
sector has just
hasn't seemed historically well equipped
to deal with so i think that's
absolutely right there's a there's a
kind of middle ground between
particularly between kind of late stage
venture and project finance where you've
got technologies that have been
tested and proven at pilot scale but
which have not gotten full commercial
deployment and thus have a difficult
time getting bank financing whether it's
equity or debt
um and so there's a there's a need to
finance those kinds of projects and i
think there are some new players who are
entering that market but you're right
the scale of capital needed to build
large facilities whether it's
manufacturing or
whether it's on the generation side or
certainly has been true in biofuels and
so on
can be
hundreds of millions of dollars
the other interesting thing though
that's happening is through these kinds
of partnerships you're seeing deals
where larger companies that have that
capability both from a balance sheet
perspective and a technical perspective
are partnering with the smaller
companies to sort of say outsource that
activity to us
i'll give you an example there's an led
company called bridge lux
that did a partnership with toshiba and
basically toshiba had all of this
excess fabricating
capacity from semiconductors that they
basically weren't using because of a
change in standards and they figured out
that they could take what was unused
manufacturing capacity and apply it to
this led technology and so the two
companies are working together and it's
a win-win because they've taken uh
something that was under utilized asset
and applied it in a new area and they've
licensed that technology and now they
have a play in that space so figuring
out those kinds of partnerships where
you know the larger player has the
capital to put to work but also the
technological know-how or an asset
that's underutilized makes a lot of
sense
uh we'll go there and then there
um i'm curious about why you chose the
power sector to start with and what else
you looked at or
yeah yeah
so
you know it's a good question we
also i think i didn't mention this but
part of our philosophy is that this all
has to be very relationship driven and
we have worked closely with those three
companies that i mentioned duke energy
general electric and national grid and
at the c-suite level and we believe that
having the buy-in of a senior executive
ideally the chief executive of the
company is key to getting the kind of
partnerships that we want to drive
because the just the time it can take
otherwise is
kind of
difficult to
to swallow so that was one reason we
started in that area
but we also canvassed a bunch of the
other verticals that i looked at or i
mentioned earlier
and there's interest from major players
in those sectors as well we just thought
we need to start somewhere and frankly
there's so much at stake in the power
sector i mean it's obviously from an
environmental standpoint uh the largest
impact that's out there
and there's also another dynamic which
is you know probably uh obvious but
that's the utilities don't generally
compete with one another because they're
regulated entities you can get multiple
utilities working side by side and even
though i've worked in other industries
like real estate and transportation and
waste management you know in those
sectors there's more cutthroat
competition so the idea of having
a gm or a ford or a toyota or a vw kind
of partner in an initial network cluster
seemed a little bit more challenging
than getting a duke in a national grid
who are two of the biggest utilities
in the western world
but they don't compete
so it was there was a strategic decision
there
could you talk a little bit about the
process between finding a growth company
and connecting it to
your partners and what kind of screening
criteria that you apply when you're
looking at these new opportunities sure
i mean we're using a lot of the same
criteria that any venture investor would
look at so obviously wanting to make
sure that there's a strong team
in place that they've got good
technology they've got defensible
ip or other unique assets
but because we're really looking at this
from the standpoint of how we can scale
up innovation we want to make sure that
the company has a solution or an
offering that's really market ready
so if they're in the early stage of kind
of working through the technology
development and testing and piloting it
it's probably not going to be ready yet
unless as we talked about earlier uh
it's a business model innovation in
which case it might get kind of
moved to the head of the
list in some ways because there's just
less technology risk there but by means
by by and large we're looking for
companies that have you know those good
fundamentals and are solving a challenge
or a problem that the large corporate
entities in our network are
are working on so it's i would say
that's maybe the other distinction is
we're going to be very driven
by the needs of our network and venture
capital generally is um
what's the right way to say it more
supply side focused right they come up
with they have a technology or company
that they identify they want to make
sure there's a good team and good
technology and then kind of only later
do they often say now who are we going
to sell this to
we're going to look at it from the
opposite direction what's the problem
that our network's trying to solve
and then who are the companies that can
solve that challenge
yes
from a first year graduate student from
school of forestry um you mentioned it
before i'm curious about as broad scale
move up move to other sectors how does
the strategy will change or the dynamics
of the partnerships will change and
do you foresee any challenges
well i think the you know as we talked
about before the dynamics in each of
these markets is a little different um
the way i think about it you know going
back to kind of one of the images i'll
just show it to you again as we talk
about it we really want to think about
this as one network one big distributed
network like paul buran talked about
with multiple nodes in the network so
power is a node waste water real estate
transportation
but the idea is that you can pull them
together
in
areas that are of common interest so
some of the challenges and issues that
you're all
familiar with take
electric vehicles electric vehicles
would be an issue for the power network
for the transportation or the power part
of the network the transportation
cluster in the network even the real
estate cluster because where you're
going to charge these things right
so increasingly the issues that are most
germane to
energy and environment are at the
intersection of these different
industries right take another issue like
waste to energy i mean obviously that
involves companies that are
waste collectors and processors as well
as companies that need energy inputs and
feedstocks so
a lot of these issues cross the
traditional boundaries of industries
right and that's the reason we want to
create this network of
companies from different industries
stuart
oh the
power industry is dealing with a number
of issues that you raise particularly
this lack of new technology that they
can actually use and deploy there's also
a huge
gap in terms of the people that are
actually going to help run these
industries do you ever view broad scale
as being a way to create a network of
new leaders within an industry and how
does that how would that actually
germinate come true because right now
they simply can't fill the gap of people
that are
that they need to work in these
industries and be the innovators that's
a great question um
and a natural coming from the head of
seabay
because it's true that these challenges
and industries will need new leaders
to figure out how these problems get
solved and i do think that you know as i
said earlier innovation is not just
about technology it's it's often about
the culture of the enterprise and that's
why we're trying to marry
entrepreneurial culture to
the assets that large organizations have
but it also means having the right
people who will think creatively and in
new ways about problem solving
and so i believe very much that there's
a need to get new folks into these kinds
of institutions and
too often
you go into meetings at some of these
companies and there's a
attitude like well we've never done that
this way in this industry so why should
we start doing it now
and the ceos who i talk to are
frustrated with that they actually would
like to see
people who are
risk takers and um who are trying to
drive change come into their enterprises
and they they try to hire them um but
you know it often it often is tough to
get to people to come into those
industries when they've got other
options available to them but i think
there are great opportunities for folks
from for example the cba program and som
and fds here
to go into these institutions to be
those kinds of catalysts of change and
to be the ones who can actually drive it
okay
well thank you all for your attention
your great questions i've really enjoyed
the dialogue and happy to talk to any of
you after thanks a lot